so i was i was away uh when this big
bombshell dropped
big big bombshell the biggest
bombshelliest
bombshell of them all but fortunately
you know um i could still weigh in
because just last night there was
another
there was another bombshell related to
this another development we'll talk
about that in a second
i'm referring of course to the melania
tapes melania trump the first lady
used to be friends with a vile wretch of
a woman
named stephanie winston wolkov and i
only call her that because i i
call her a a vile wretch of a woman
because she was secretly recording for a
period of time
uh secretly recording her friend and you
know i would say that secretly recording
someone who
you claim to be your friend so that you
can give the tapes to the media later
i think that qualifies you for the vile
wretch camp personally
um and uh let's so so the
the the the first tape that came out
this was last week
you probably heard the first one but
let's play it again anyway this was the
um
tape that was released a few days ago
media is making a big deal of it but
here's what was said
i'm completed i'm the same like him i
support him i don't say
enough i don't do enough no it's where i
christmas stuff and decoration but i
need to do it right yeah but
imagine 100 you have no choice and
okay and then i do it and i say that i'm
working on christmas uh planning for the
christmas
and they said oh what about the children
that they were separated
give me a break
where they were saying anything when
obama did that i know
i cannot go i i was trying
to get the kid reunited with the mom
i didn't have a chance needs to go
through the process and through the law
but here's my thing you hear what you
just said but instead of that
if if you just your messaging
you you were so loved you could not do
the story
we put it out they would not do the
story
until you would not believe it they
would not
do the story because no they are not
they would not do the story because they
they are
they are against us because they are
liberal media
yeah if i go to fox they will do the
story i don't want to go to fox
so that tape is supposed to prove
something i don't know exactly
i don't know what they thought it proves
what it proves to me
is that melania is much nicer and more
buttoned up um than a lot of people are
in private including me
okay she was being recorded by a trusted
confidant
and that's the worst thing they caught
her saying was that
you know what has to be the worst there
are a lot of tapes out there but they're
going to lead with their
their the biggest one the worst one
they're going to lead with that
and that's it i can just tell you this
if a trusted confidant was recording me
secretly for weeks on end you would hear
a lot worse than that a lot worse
i can tell you and that's the irony is
that both
trump and his wife have been secretly
recorded by people they trusted
for trump it was michael uh cohen and
somehow
they weren't caught saying anything
horrible
they're actually it would seem they are
less offensive in their private lives
than the average american that was the
surprising thing from
for me with with the trump tapes
especially is that he's actually
he's more outrageous in public than he
is in private
um so what do you hear in that tape
melania complains about the media
rightfully so
um you know because they refuse to cover
the good things that she and her husband
are doing she's complaining about that
she complains about christmas
decorations
the left tried to make that into a oh
she's waging a war on christmas oh
please
who doesn't complain about christmas
complaining about christmas decorations
is a time-honored american tradition
it's as american as as blue jeans and
drive-throughs it's it's the most
american thing in the world
we that's this is what we do we put up
the christmas decorations and we
complain about them
we complain about them while we're
putting them up
anyone who ever grew up you know
watching their dad hang the christmas
lights outside
you can attest to this all the colorful
language that came out of your dad's
mouth
as he was trying to hang the christmas
lights um
and so that was the first thing uh the
worst thing she did was she complained
about uh
christmas decorations then last night
another tape was dropped this one
is even at this one's probably even more
shockingly unshocking than the first
this is what she said listen
uh annie leibovitz shot the porn
hooker and she will be one of the issues
september or october
what do you mean she who she shot the
porn hooker
stormy yeah and that's it she refers to
stormy daniels as a porn hooker
which she is it's a pretty decent
uh description
and that's it there's no there's really
not much else to it than that
i i gotta i'm i am really really
surprised i i just sort of assume
can you imagine okay what if there were
michelle tapes what if michelle obama
had been secretly recorded
by her most trusted ally and friend in
secret
for you know for weeks what kind of
stuff do you think we'd hear
i'm thinking probably worse stuff than
i don't want to hang the christmas
decorations if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up
and share it with all your friends